good morning everyone thank you for
being here thank you to Yale in the
center for interdisciplinary research on
aids for inviting me in particular Paul
Elaine Jeanette gay leaf and Julie made
it all very possible for me to be here
it's a little hard to follow after
hearing the news about Elizabeth Taylor
so I'm going to yield a minute of my
precious time for us to take a moment of
silence and remember her contribution to
HIV
thank you so Dame Elizabeth Taylor was
someone who committed herself to the
fight against aids from the very
beginning of the epidemic and I was
asked to talk about 30 years of AIDS
research and what I've chosen to do is
talk a little bit about the history of
HIV and AIDS research and policy
actually with a focus on what Jim Curran
called the nasty Sciences which is the
work we all do in particular social and
behavioral research but also
epidemiology and other Sciences in which
we focus on sex and drug use and all
those nasty things and that's part of
the story about how we have fared as
disciplines and as part of the research
response to HIV and AIDS over 30 years
in the u.s. in particular and how our
work as scientists intersects with
policy and programmatic work as well so
I'm going to begin with a timeline and
this is one I with the able help of my
staff who know how to do PowerPoint
better than I do constructed and we
looked at extant timelines of which
there are actually a few good ones out
there and I wanted to highlight just a
few in the realm of research and policy
and the point I'm going to make is that
some are events or activities or
episodes that are really familiar to
everyone not just those of us in the
room but some are things that occurred
at the same moment that got much less
attention or that are very particularly
important to our nasty sciences so I
don't know if you can see this so I'm
going to highlight these little boxes as
they appear beginning in 1981 when we
had by everyone everyone's familiar with
the CDC's MMWR reporting the first cases
of aids and night in 1981 but in the
same year the Reagan administration
moved to defund all social sciences at
the NIH in something you hear much less
about and which has had an impact on the
response to HIV by the behavioral and
Social Sciences in particular ever since
in 1983 the NIH began awarding grants
for AIDS research
that did right from the start include
behavioral and Social Research donde
charleigh had one of the first grants
looking at risk associated with
injection drug use in 1986 at an amfar
event in fact President Ronald Reagan
for the very first time uttered the word
aids that got a lot of press and in the
same year ni-mh began funding its aids
research centers in 1989 and obviously
I'm skipping some years just for the
sake of time in 1989 the National
Institute on Allergy and Infectious
Diseases established the community
programs for clinical research on AIDS
which some of you participated in I know
Jerry did the CPC RA and that was well
known in the AIDS research response but
it was also the year that the Bush
administration defunded a peer-reviewed
approved and partially funded grant to
the University of North Carolina for a
survey of teenage sexual behavior or the
sexual behaviors of teenagers so that
was one of the first real significant
episodes of politics or ideology
trumping science and abrogating peer
review in 1991 the Institute of Medicine
issued a report that called for
strengthening the office of AIDS
research which was an office created
somewhat virtually a couple years
earlier to manage what it was a very
quickly growing portfolio of AIDS
research at the NIH and to really help
target and coordinate the response but
at the city in the same year the Bush
administration denied funding to a
second survey of sexual behavior this
time that was going to be among adults a
nationally representative survey of
adult sexual behavior done by
researchers at the University of Chicago
so this was another one that was peer
reviewed and approved through the
Institute at NIH but squashed at the
Department of Health and Human Services
so those two episodes of denying funding
to research on sexual behaviors are
fairly early in the epidemic really set
us back in 1993 as you all know the CDC
it's definition of HIV and AIDS I think
we were still calling it mostly AIDS at
the time to include conditions
particularly experienced by women like
cervical cancer so we had the expansion
of the definition of what constituted
AIDS and that's fairly well known during
that year the office of AIDS research at
NIH was given statutory authority by law
to organize coordinate the scientific
program of AIDS research across the
whole of NIH and budget authority to
manage the money and what's important
about that legislation why I mentioned
that is because in the law were stated
areas of scientific research that had to
be staffed and covered funded and
monitored including behavioral and
Social Sciences Research that was an
effort from advocates in 1996 we all
know we had the research showing the
efficacy and effectiveness of
combination therapy for treating HIV and
that was also the year that the NIH
office of AIDS research convened an
external review of the entire AIDS
research program to retool it and
refocus it was called the Levine
committee named after its chair and that
committee report put new emphasis on
prevention and prevention science
vaccine research certainly had a lot of
attention but in addition the committee
talked about an interdisciplinary
approach to HIV prevention science that
would cut across biomedical behavioral
and social science and out of that grew
a special initiative in the office I was
there at the time in which we were able
to fund was with separate money on a
quicker basis some innovative prevention
science projects a number of you were
recipients of those awards so that
helped move us towards a more
interdisciplinary prevention science
approach in 1997 the Department of
Health and Human Services issued its
first guidelines for the treatment of
adults and adolescents with HIV and AIDS
but it was also the year that aids and
behavior is a journal emerged which has
become very important in showcasing
behavioral and social research it's also
the year we had what's called an NIH
consensus conference it's a particular
mechanism in which
people are brought together where
there's some controversy in the
scientific literature and come to some
kind of consensus as sort of an
allnighter and people sleep deprived so
you have to wonder about the
recommendations but this was really
monumental because it was the first one
to showcase the efficacy of behavioral
interventions and particularly supported
by the NIH and it in 1999 we had the
research that showed a simpler and more
affordable version of preventing
mother-to-child transmission with the
medication and antiretroviral in this
case nevirapine that was released and it
was also the year that the CDC published
its first version of the compendium of
effective behavioral interventions which
over time evolved into the Debbie
diffusion or dissemination of effective
behavioral interventions or
evidence-based I forget what the acronym
means love it or hate it that's when
Debbie was born in the year 2000 we had
the first international aids conference
in a developing country in the southern
hemisphere that was held in Durban South
Africa and brought attention to the need
and the possibilities of scaling up
antiretroviral treatment to developing
countries hardest hit by the epidemic a
true turning point in science and
advocacy on a global level it was also
the year in which the journal aids
published a special issue on structural
interventions which was headed by Esther
sumotori oh from the CDC but where Kim
Blankenship and Mike Marcin and others
who you know were very actively involved
in had articles so that was the first
official scientific publication
recognition of sort of social and
structural approaches to HIV skipping to
2003 we all know the President Bush
introduced PEPFAR which was the u.s.
global aids program that has grown too
grown to about a 50 billion dollar
program for prevention care treatment
and support around the world and the wh
0 the World Health Organization
initiated a three by five campaign which
was to see that three million people
were on antiretroviral treatment around
the world by the year two thousand five
but for us in the nasty sciences it was
also the year in which
traditional values coalition a very
religiously based organization basically
a minister and his daughter with a lot
of press effectively launched an attack
on a couple hundred NIH grants and the
researchers behind them based on the
content of those grants which had to do
with sexual behavior drug use abortion
family planning homosexuality and things
I just didn't like and this was a huge
ordeal as many as you may recall in fact
I think I came to visit you in 2004 soon
after this occurred and we talked a lot
about politics and science then but that
was yet again another full-scale
onslaught and the traditional values
coalition although they were the
initiators they had allies in Congress
and in the department of health and
human services at the time that put the
fear and everyone excuse me I'm sorry
moving along a few years again in the
interest of time in 2008 the CDC issued
its new estimates of HIV infection which
as you recall said well we thought we
had 40,000 new infections per year
fairly stable for 10 years it was more
likely 56,000 plus or minus and that
suggested that we weren't necessarily
doing all that we should be doing in our
prevention response or that what we were
doing was not necessarily as effective
as it could be in moving to 2010 just
this last year we had a lot of
excitement in the scientific world when
the data from two studies looking at
using antiretroviral therapy for
prevention purposes were presented at
two major conferences so the first was a
micro beside trial a vaginal gel the
study was called Caprice 2004 conducted
in South Africa and showed about a
thirty-nine percent risk reduction among
women on the gel and the second was the
pre exposure prophylaxis study published
in November this past year that showed
44 now it's about forty two percent
efficacy risk reduction in HIV
acquisition among gay and other men who
have sex with men and transgender
male-to-female in
be America's so these were big deal and
things are happening as a result of
those but at the same time in fact at
the conference where the microbicides
study was presented there was also data
presented on the efficacy and
effectiveness of a conditional cash
transfer project so this was a social
structural intervention the world
bank-funded in malawi that showed that
if you provided young women and their
families some cash money you could
reduce sexual risks of HIV transmission
by reducing the need for young women to
engage in transactional sex for goods or
money or support or school fees and also
to develop some economic independence
and empowerment among them and that
showed evidence of efficacy in reducing
HIV transmission not just psycho and
social outcomes got much less press
though and of course of course most
importantly as Paul mentioned we now
have and we had released in july of 2010
the first true national hiv/aids
strategy for the united states and i'm
going to say more about that so that's
my quick march of history with just a
few highlights to make some points about
the accomplishments and challenges we
have faced in our nasty sciences but I
want to spend the next part of the talk
focusing much more in the current
context in frames because I think we all
want to be forward-looking and obviously
these frames are very much affected by
our history and you'll see themes that
repeat over and again in the next
however many years were at this but I
think that we're at a very interesting
time and I wanted to talk about what are
some of the most current contextual
factors influencing what we do now what
we're going to be doing and how things
are being framed so beginning with the
national HIV and AIDS strategy I know
you're going to have a panel on this
later in the day so I did want to bring
a little bit of attention to it in the
morning also because this strategy
released by the president actually
started with the community there were
three of us who began a campaign for a
National AIDS strategy based on some
reports that have been published over
the years saying we really should have a
national plan so it was myself for the
San Francisco AIDS Foundation Rebecca
Hague at
to Action Council and AIDS Action
Massachusetts and Chris Collins who was
independent at the time and that works
for amfar and the three of us put time
staffing and money into organizing what
became a coalition and that became all
modesty aside a social movement in the
sense that we had hundreds of
organizations thousands of people who
became involved in promoting a National
AIDS strategies we started in 2007 we
aimed at the presidential election we
ended up with every candidate committing
to instituting some kind of national
strategy when he or she I think it
became he pretty quickly were elected
and President Obama committed pretty
much to the view we had of what the
National AIDS strategy ought to look
like and now we're in the implementation
phase of that so on this slide I know
it's not perceptible I just wanted to
highlight a letter because that shows
that the community started this there's
a core group of people whose names you
can't read we devised a framework that
then informed what actually became the
national strategy and we continue to
monitor that so the national strategy is
interesting because it begins with a
vision statement that I'm not sure any
of us would have expected to see in the
most recent prior administration's that
the United States will become a place
where new HIV infections are rare and
when they do occur every person
regardless of age gender race ethnicity
sexual orientation gender identity or
socio-economic circumstance will have
unfettered access to high-quality
life-extending care free from stigma and
discrimination now you could never get
any better yourselves could you have
pretty remarkable
and as I think you know the National
AIDS strategy which is now a document
and it's in its implementation and
operationalization phase has four goals
the three first ones are the real
primary epidemic goals the fourth is
about coordination and the government
and each of these goals reduce the first
being reducing new HIV and incidents has
specific targets this was our aim and
having a National AIDS strategy and it's
what the government is committed to
targeted measurable accountable outcome
so for prevention you can see the some
of the targets for increasing access to
care and improving health outcomes for
people living with HIV and AIDS there
are targets and I'm doing I'm going to
flash these quickly to keep you awake
for reducing HIV related health
disparities recognizing class race
gender based disparities we have some
targets as well around increasing
diagnosis and access to care and then
for their fourth goal there's there are
some loser targets but they're mainly
highlights of how we should see a more
coordinated and consolidated federal
response better interagency coordination
and data collection and use and all that
now there was no explicit goal there is
no explicit goal related to research in
the National AIDS strategy but by all
accounts research underpins everything
and so in order to make sure that
research was recognized in the strategy
as it was being developed and in the
implementation phases this external
group of advocates convene a number of
consultations of people like yourselves
including one focused on research and
that group came up with a number of
recommendations that we then submitted
to the White House and are part of their
implementation phase so you can see that
some of the recommendations and these
are sort of general they're not about
specific topics to be research but they
have to do with things like ensuring
that we can continue to do basic science
including basic social and behavioral
science you know that word typically is
only meant to refer to biological or
Natural Sciences basic science but we
have basic science to the
mental mechanisms operating the brain
and the human person that contribute to
vulnerability or resilience so the
importance of continuing basic research
expanding implementation science which
is all the rage now how to make sure
what works works well and so on we that
group made a point of saying we've got
to keep funding aids research and of
course the ever-present coordination
better coordination across federal
agencies including things around study
sections and the suggestion to give the
secretary a special fund to jumpstart
projects like we got to do at the office
of AIDS research as I mentioned earlier
around novel prevention science
approaches a similar idea was
promulgated for the people implementing
the national strategy the Secretary's
levels so that they could get new things
happening and the point was to say we
want to think about research in the
context of the National AIDS strategy
goals and in service to them now a
second effort was undertaken by the
office of AIDS research itself who
convened a social and behavioral science
think-tank some of you were there in
September I was co-chair with Tom coats
and we were asked to put emphasis on the
social in the Social and Behavioral
Sciences and again come up with
recommendations for the NIH office of
AIDS research about what to support and
how to support research that would be
responsive to the National AIDS strategy
goals we had a number of thank you we
had a number of work groups I'm just
showing you those quickly here so you
could see how we organized our
conversation and we actually had the
groups start talking to each other in
the months before the think tank so when
they came to the think tank they'd
already come up with some ideas that
were presented and then mold over and we
at the end of the think tank had a
report full of recommendations and we
also had our own vision statement for
the National hiv/aids strategy vision
and goals to be realized a complete
coherent coordinated response is
required that integrates case-finding
diagnosis treatment prevention and care
in the context of full recognition of
the
ortant of community involvement and
respect for human rights and a robust
social behavioral research portfolio
portfolio from discovery basic
behavioral and social research through
implementation is essential so that was
our sort of vision statement and then we
made recommendations in a number of key
areas related to the fact that we study
particularly the social end of the
spectrum complex models pull people in
whole environments influenced by lots of
things going on in their lives and we
still are struggling with how to do that
methodologically and theoretically we
talked about social process and we made
recommendations related to supporting
research that actually studies social
change that's scary particularly to
federal funders because the social
change might involve changing them but
it's still essential to HIV and AIDS
because we've all been transformed by
the epidemic of course there's social
and behavioral research that should be
attended with biomedical technologies
and this is what I'm going to highlight
now in case I forget to say it at the
end a lot of folks nowadays when they
think about our sciences they tend to
think of us chiefly as handmaidens to
the biological technophile medical
technologies being developed of course
we need behavioral research that will
help us develop and implement
microbicides and pre exposure
prophylaxis and male circumcision and
those sorts of strategies so it's very
much the research in service to those
technologies rather than the research in
and of itself so we recognize that it's
important to have those contributions
and we want to also still keep focus on
our own obviously a new area for
research that some of you are already
engaged in is around new information and
communications technologies how those
both fill meant epidemics by having
people in much more social contact than
they might otherwise be and hooking up
and those kinds of things but how they
can also be sites and venues for HIV
prevention lots of emphasis on
implementation and effectiveness
research we have thousands of behavioral
interventions that show efficacy but how
do we know about effectiveness how
things collectively work in the real
world with what impact on the epidemic
on just individual behavioral change we
talked about those research areas but we
also talked about the management of
research because i think as those of you
engaged in research would attest
sometimes it's the bureaucracy the
administrative angle that really can
bollix things up so one big area that we
have to look a lot at is the use of
existing data sets that are out there
but untapped or unshared that was big
for this group of people and that we
actually this group went far enough to
say that scientific peer review as much
as it should be focused on the merits of
a project just for that project science
really should take into account the
public health impact we're getting a
little bit more clear about that we
talked about need for training
mechanisms and for more novel and nimble
funding mechanisms things that don't
take so long and can be responsive as
the epidemic changes quickly so that's
the sort of National AIDS strategy in
the role of research is one current
context in frame I wanted to also talk
about prevention and prevention research
itself because that's what most people
here I think are engaged in not entirely
but and there's a particular way in
which prevention is now being talked
about and it's some version of
combination prevention here is the
official definition from un aids that
emphasizes strategic simultaneous use of
different kinds of prevention different
modes different levels that respond to
specific needs of specific populations
so targeted and culturally appropriate
and that make efficient use of resources
this is just I know it's very busy but
just to show you how combination
prevention was operationalized by one
person carlos casseras from peru who
presented this at the international aids
conference so he had his version of the
intersection of structural which is
along the outside i'm not using the
pointer because it only works on one of
these so i'll use my hands the
structural stuff on the outside the
biomedical and the little greenish bulb
and the behavioral strategies and the
bluish bulb and how those intersect even
as there are particular ways to focus so
that's one version of combination
prevention here's another one this is my
redrawing of a slide that John
jano Merman presented he's the head of
the division of hiv/aids prevention at
CDC and he presented this at the
retrovirus conference last month so it's
very similar the intersecting element of
prevention which was based on this
famous graph looks to me like an
inflamed bubble of highly active HIV
prevention that Tom coats and colleagues
published in the lancet in 2008 that was
based on a model developed initially by
king homes but again the idea here that
like we have highly active treatment
that's about combinations targeting
different aspects of the viral lifecycle
and replication cycle we should have
combination prevention that's highly
active and takes from different fields
and addresses different aspects now in
thinking about how do you concur ties
that into an actual combination
prevention approach Audrey pettifore
who's to reach researcher at University
of North Carolina Chapel Hill work has
worked a lot in southern Africa came up
with her vision of what might be
combination prevention targeting young
women in southern Africa who are at
anywhere from two to four times greater
risk of having HIV infection than their
male counterparts and she said well it
would be a combination of an individual
behavioral change intervention or set of
interventions that get at risk reduction
condom use male and female negotiation
skills and relationships those sorts of
things plus pre exposure prophylaxis
might be oral by a prep or a pill it
might be vaginal or rectal gel or other
kind of formulations so some version of
pre exposure prophylaxis a conditional
cash transfer intervention that provides
resources to the young women are their
families for the reasons I mentioned
earlier and community mobilization with
men that would address what are
experienced by men and women of all
gender and sexual orientations alike as
somewhat oppressive gender norms around
masculinity in many cases and that
together that combination would help
reduce HIV risk among those young women
so that's one operationalization of the
notion
we have another version of combination
prevention this is the NIH's version
which of course turns everything into a
randomized controlled trial and they are
funding something called mp3 which are
prevention packages methods for
prevention package is something like
that there are six projects being funded
in different parts of the world and
here's how they describe what they're
looking at there they're beginning with
feasibility and modeling studies to see
what are the different prevention
strategies that can be packaged for a
target population defined by geography
or some characteristic of identity that
would then be tested in randomized
trials to show efficacy and
effectiveness so I can talk more about
one of those later but in the interest
of time I won't yet another version is
sorry a lot of the combination
prevention approach is also being
expressed in something that you might
hear more about later from Steve Morin
and others the 12 city project or the
enhanced comprehensive HIV prevention
planning Egypt project that is becoming
the cornerstone operational project of
the National AIDS strategy it's attempt
to coordinate federal agencies and their
activities in targeted communities in
metropolitan statistical areas 12 of
them to have the greatest impact
possible on HIV prevention care and
treatment and health outcomes so these
are the areas that are being involved in
this project and they're just in a
planning phase now but it's a version of
combination not just prevention but also
it's linked to treatment and care so
looking at effective interventions
effective strategies and how those can
be combined for greater impact in a
geographic location yet another version
was prevent presented by John o Merman
again from CDC at the retrovirus meeting
that he's now calling high-impact
prevention and I think this will become
the nomenclature of CDC whose components
are listed here effectiveness and cost
feasibility coverage and targeting and
prioritizing so my point is that
whatever we call it combination by any
other name highly active prevention
prevent
packages high-impact prevention all
versions are emphasizing multi-level
multimodal and multi or
transdisciplinary approaches and I would
say this is an accomplishment of our
community in really emphasizing that HIV
is a virus it's a pathogen but it is
transmitted by human beings usually in
duo's in the course of human
relationships that exist in social
political and economic context and we
have to address all of that
scientifically and part of the point
that John Merman made in introducing
this high-impact prevention is it's not
just an additive of this intervention
Plus that they're not all equally
effective and not all equally valuable
and so we need to be really targeted and
effective in what we do so the third can
context and frame i wanted to mention
i'm going to speed up a little bit here
in the interest of time is the one that
we all fear the most and that's the
existing and looming budget cuts these
are challenging times for HIV prevention
again this is from mermans presentation
at Croy you can see some of the
specifics about the level of the federal
deficit the amount of funding cuts that
states and localities are experiencing
all of us are at the receiving end of
this many community-based organizations
around the country are actually closing
their shops some of the larger ones like
mine are absorbing programs where we can
and in addition to prevention their
shortages there are more and more people
waiting for coverage under the aids drug
assistance plan what happens in this
scenario is that many people inside the
Apes advocacy community as well as
outside and in Congress start to say
let's rob Peter to pay Paul and say
things like let's defund vaccine
research and put the money into the a
doubt because a tap is you know real and
in your face it's people with HIV who
don't have affordable access to
medications so you see people proposing
those kinds of trade-offs which are
quite dangerous but understandable now
for all you nih research geeks in the
room i wanted to be sure to have a
funding chart to show research is not
immune from these budget cuts and
although the nih
aids research budget has grown
precipitously since the beginning in
1982 as you can see from this graph
graph which i'm not sure that shading
shows through very well that put that
particular inclined eyes the near
doubling of the AIDS research budget
along with the near doubling of the nih
overall budget between 1998 and 2003 but
then things start leveling off i wanted
to show you that not all research is
treated equally as well and there are a
lot of reasons this is the case but just
to make the point if you look at the
dark purpley blue line since the one two
three fourth one down that social and
behavioral research these are the five
categories by which aids research
historically has been codified and
followed over the years at the nih long
story i could say more about later but
it's a way to monitor expenditures in
8th research and behavioral and social
research has always received between
about 12 and a half and 14 and a half
percent of the total aids research
budget so not a huge amount and you can
see these are all going flat the latter
years or projections again we can talk
more about the details of that later
amfar just issued a couple months ago a
very important issue brief looking at
what would be the impact of one of the
proposals hovering pretty seriously in
Congress amongst the republicans which
is to roll back funding for all federal
programs to two thousand eight levels
this would have a huge impact on HIV and
AIDS programs including but not limited
to research as you can see here and in
fact for NIH the estimated cut would be
about 1.6 billion dollars out of a 30
billion dollar budget or about 5% 5.2
percent now this may not sound like a
whole heck of a lot but when you're
dealing with the inflation of biomedical
research and you have a lot of
continuing grants that should be funded
it's going to be quite serious if that
gets through and of course I don't know
if you can read this cartoon but this
harkens back to those nasty days of
politics and science and the prior
administration which never quite go away
regardless of administration or Congress
and this refers to this
who looks suspiciously like President
Bush we need to increase funding for
science science is important then we
can't afford to run out of it if we
didn't have any science we wouldn't have
anything to politicize so that's not
gone away in fact one of the amendments
to the bill HR 1 that was intended to
fund the government through the fiscal
year you could again a long process was
proposing to cut specific studies again
from the NIH that had been peer reviewed
and approved for funding if not already
partially funded one of which was
looking at appropriate and proper condom
use skills and adult males which of
course relates to HIV and AIDS so grants
are still under attack at every turn
particularly when their budgets are
tight the last frame I wanted to mention
that operates as much of the global
level as the domestic is this movement
from an emergency result in response to
sustainability and of course it's
connected to the issue of budget and
politics and the history of AIDS as it
evolves over time and in lots of places
and you can see this theme and this
frame in the President's Emergency Plan
for AIDS research the PEPFAR program
that says they're now going to focus on
transitioning from an emergency response
to promoting sustainable country
programs and it was very evident as the
theme of AIDS 20 31 which was a large
somewhat virtual non-governmental non
Association effort spearheaded by the
previous head of you and AIDS Peter P
Hut to do a visioning exercise of where
do we want to be in 20 30 150 years from
the initial reporting of AIDS and what
do we need to do now to get to that
place the reason I wanted to mention
that in addition to the sustainability
frame is that even in that case and this
just wrapped up this last year one of
the working groups with science and
technology and in their overall report
reviewing progress to date and current
prospects they have one little section
on behavioral prevention that says
although the agenda for behavioral
prevention research is beyond the scope
of this paper and outside the remit of
the science and technology working group
developments of behavioral prevention
will inevitably have an impact on the
design and interpretation of biomedical
HIV prevention
studies so there we are marginalized
again not part of science and technology
and in service to biomedical
technologies so the more things change
the more they don't but I wanted to end
on a more optimistic note than that we
will see budget fights will see politics
we'll see scientific resistance inside
the scientific community and outside to
the kinds of nasty science work that we
do but there is an opportunity all these
sort of negative things give us an
opportunity to focus our work to be more
targeted and more responsive to the
public health needs and impact that our
research can have and that all of this
has to occur in collaboration between
research and communities and their
advocates so with that I'd like to close
and thank you very much for your
attention